I think there are two great gay
Americans obviously and that is Abraham
Lincoln and Wool Whitman
I think it's obvious obvious that the
man was gay and not many people sleep
with other men and when the other man
leaves have nervous breakdowns look very
few other presidents in history have
have slept with a man in their own bed
in the White House while their wife
slept next door
it is staring us in the face it was
written at the time
historical consensus is slowly shifting
it's far too dangerous right now for
people to acknowledge by which I mean
not only was he had a homosexual
orientation but he actually was sexually
active as well which is which is really
quite remarkable
and I know this is controversial there
was a amazingly I unfortunately flawed
because the guy didn't finish died
before he finished it the intimate life
of Abraham Lincoln by sea a trip which
really blew a lot of this stuff out of
the water and mainstream Lincoln
scholarship for a long time completely
dismissed this in fact but you're
beginning to see in scholarship out
there and emerging scholarship that what
people at the time called his lavender
streak at the time is is a core way of
understanding who this human being was
not that he didn't also function
heterosexually gay people in these
periods of time had to and the social
and psychological pressures that
required people to adhere to
heterosexual norms were overwhelming and
not that we will ever find you know
proof of such but just the simple facts
I told you which no one can dispute a
pretty remarkable now they have to
appeal I think Oh men slept with each
other all the time in the in the in log
cabins in the 19th century and there was
this principle of intimacy and
friendship that was we've sexualized and
blah blah blah blah all which is true
but in the White House when you were
already married I mean I staggering and
no one disputes these facts so what what
do you think
again I think the one of the great
things about a blog is to write and
think about stuff um that the people
kind of know but don't want to talk
about and and and yet which are really I
think pretty obvious but are restrained
by taboos taboos you know that's like
the race and IQ taboo like the trick
taboo like things you can't actually not
even and there may not be an answer to
these questions that we can nail down
with any certainty or that we can do so
without with without without people
cooperating or finding new sources that
confirm it but I don't see why we sure
as hell can't actually talk about it and
that's what blogging does that you can't
do when you are putting down a fact on
paper forever you know you can ask
questions as long as they're not sort of
leading and obviously malicious leaving
questions but genuine questions can we
talk about whether the Pope is gay can
we um can we talk about whether Elena
Kagan is gay uh when it would seem that
every I don't know a gay person anywhere
who believes that either of them is
straight but look I'm not wanting people
to thinks everybody's gay I'm really not
I mean I think very few people are gay
I'm a 2% at myself I um but I'm not
going to sit around and and pretend I'm
not thinking things on my blog when I am
thinking them and when I'm open to
rebuttal